the Joe Rogan experience you know only
the poo is all about an acid trip no
they said about everything a ride come
on go on the ride yeah something ride
yeah the ride at Disneyland sounds like
the worst ride of all time it's
basically an acid trip hmm I remember
one of the times I did it I went through
Disneyland high as [ __ ] and I was on the
rise like oh this is Winnie the Pooh's
he's on acid uh-huh like there's all
these visuals and everything becomes
psychedelic and the colors are weird
really yes even a video of the Winnie
the Pooh right no I'm telling you Alice
in Wonderland I'll get all right this
mushrooms is talking cats and [ __ ] no
something happens during the ride and
you go like when he goes in the way the
poo goes into dreamland
oh I don't nobody goes into dreamland
it's you're basically on acid you're
going to an acid trip just yet I was
like he's mellow he's got he's eating
honey he's got no pants mmm doesn't feel
acid he well watch this see you to do
Disney World
Disneyland Disneyland she's out here so
yeah you go through everything's normal
not really this is just pretty there's
lights and yeah you're on this little
[ __ ] thing and you're in the little
roller coaster ride and though here's
Winnie I'm floating around with a
balloon it's a kind of a cool ride you
know what it's great kind of nice my
daughters were really young I like this
oh so pretty very pretty going through
and there's a or and then there's that
other pig piglet piglet
and so then you go through a bunch of
[ __ ] happens and give me a little
fast-forward here cuz it's gonna get be
boring is the worst trip ever since that
LSD honey in that like the way I think
that's what it is
well there's that Nepal honey that's
psychedelic honey maybe that's what it
is give me a little fast forward it is a
little trippy so so that's it that's the
trip so right there so what happens
before that trip find out what happens
right before that Jamie something
happens yeah see cuz he's floating
around watch so we need the Pooh is
sitting there and then also any floats
out of his head and look I'm floating
all right like he's [ __ ] tripping
balls and then as the thing goes it goes
black and then you see Winnie floating
and then boom you're in psychedelic land
and
everything is weird and whacked-out yeah
and there's jack-in-the-box heads with
big tongues and everything is neon
psychedelic colors and the world's
melting and it's honey and honey spelled
phonetically correct let's see it now
it's got a little uh let's say fear and
loathing it's DMT this is like a DMT
trip that's what it's like all these
psychedelic things you're seeing this is
about as close to creating some sort of
a psychedelic hallucinogenic trip right
you know kids ride as you can get away
without getting arrested see I thought
you met the actual cartoon and story no
no no but this I see yeah it's like
something there's you're doing something
oh yeah why is he tripping balls you're
a millionaire in this way you spend your
time just reminding it is I didn't show
it to yet there's a VR I don't think
it's a game but I think it's like what
VR experience if they have multiple of
those but it's so ayahuasca trip what's
interesting that he's saying this is
that Terence Mckenna actually predicted
that you could recreate in the future
with virtual reality a psychedelic trip
and it would have the same exact effect
as a psychedelic trip because it would
be able to show you the same visuals you
know remember I don't know if you
remember this but there used to be you
know what phone phreaking was to
remember phone phreaking there was a way
that you could use a public pay phone
and you had a device that would make a
noise because a public pay phone right
you'd press a button like beep beep beep
beep epbb BIA well you would hold a
thing up to the phone and it would go it
would send a signal through sound and
the phone would just open up for you so
you could use it oh no core and you get
no quarter and you just start calling
people oh it was done somehow another
through sound like you would mimic the
sound the phone would make ordinarily
uh-huh so it tricked whatever was on the
other end that was waiting for the
signal that was correcting things is
this it here wow this is exciting
because I've always wanted to do it have
you done it I've done DMT I have not
done ayahuasca but this looks a lot like
the MT you've done DMT you never
mentioned it yeah oh cool yeah they're
eventually going to be able to nail this
no it
actly like what you'd experience
[Applause]